usted cómo evalúa cómo ha sido este
proceso judicial
desde el punto de vista
constitucional se han respetado todas
las garantías constitucionales
cuando uno veía el desarrollo del
proceso se respetaba la ley de
procedimiento penal y desde el punto de
vista no hay violaciones a ninguna es
más Fijate Santiago que como hablamos
hace un ratito ahora ella va a tener la
posibilidad de los recursos Entonces yo
creo que es más era Fíjate que recién en
lo que ella estaba exponiendo Ella decía
que ella es muy deteriorizar y hace un
tiempo hablaba de lower y del partido
judicial y obviamente que ahora
desemboca las dos en las dos palabras
que recién dijiste el sistema para
Estatal y la mafia judicial que dice que
va todo por fuera del resultado
electoral pero creo que acá en Argentina
en Latinoamérica en los Estados Unidos
en cualquier país de Europa de África
donde sea donde hay un sistema judicial
todos sabemos que son tres poderes que
están completamente separados que tienen
relaciones funcionales para poder
gobernar por eso está dividido en ramas
cada uno de los poderes y en esa
división hay una Independencia Que
vuelvo a lo que sostenemos acá y lo que
vos me preguntaste con respecto a las
garantías una de las garantías
fundamentales que se respetaron es la
igualdad ante la ley es decir ella fue
juzgada bajó el procedimiento que juzgan
a cualquier persona de Argentina y esa
garantía que tiene cualquier persona son
las que ella en esta oportunidad va a
poder llevar adelante con los recursos
que tiene a mano para subir como te dije
a casación y como última ratio a la
Corte Suprema hablando de esa necesaria
no por supuesto para toda democracia
independencia de los poderes Cristina
Fernández de kirchner no deja de hacer
referencia no a vínculos entre jueces y
el expresidente Mauricio macri Cuál es
su postura al respecto
mira en realidad si yo tengo que ser
objetivo este la justicia Argentina
tiene una deuda con la con con nosotros
con con los ciudadanos de a pie Yo creo
que la argentina se merece una reforma
del poder judicial pero esa reforma
judicial tiene que ser pensada y
trabajada y participativa es decir donde
todos tienen que tener derecho a
participar y a dar las propuestas para
que para tener el mejor producto no se
puede reformar la justicia solamente con
un color político esto lo mismo cuando
en el año noventa y cuatro se reformó la
Constitución cuando se reformó la
Constitución argentina se reformó
sentándose los dos partidos mayoritarios
en una mesa y resolviendo y firmando una
un núcleo de coincidencias básicas acá
tiene que pasar lo mismo tiene que
sentarse toda la dirigencia política los
actores sociales los actores económicos
Y de alguna manera En definitiva
resolver el problema que tiene la
justicia Argentina principalmente sabes
con qué Santiago con la lentitud vos
Fijate que esta causa que hoy estamos
que están rutilante y estamos todos
discutiendo la denuncia se inició el año
catorce años para poder concluir Recién
ahora con una sentencia de un tribunal
oral si sumamos dos o tres años más
vamos a terminar cumpliendo el récord de
diecisiete años para poder obtener una
sentencia sobre saquemos el nombre de
Cristina sobre cualquier funcionario
Público de la Argentina Diego un otro
detalle no que tampoco es muy conocido
quizás para la audiencia internacional
pero Cristina ha hecho referencia varias
veces a que esto ya habrían sido como se
conoce no cosa juzgada no en su momento
por otro juez que habría traspasado la
responsabilidad hacia el sur no hacia la
provincia de Santa Cruz y el hecho de la
Perdón las acusaciones habrían quedado
así habría sido absuelta Qué pasó en ese
todo ese trayecto que como bien decías
porque esto comenzó hace más de 10 años
Bueno eso fue una una etapa del proceso
penal donde bien lo dijiste vos y lo
dijo este tu corresponsal acá en Buenos
Aires el juez hercolini había comenzado
a investigar se había hecho una denuncia
en la provincia de Santa Cruz y la
provincia de Santa Cruz habían comenzado
a investigar también a otro juez Federal
pero qué pasa vos tenés este en el
proceso penal y no quiero pobre a la
gente que nos esté mirando este
apabullarla vos tenés fueros de
atracción Entonces como había el colini
enviado la causa Santa Cruz y después el
juez de Santa Cruz termina este
resolviendo otra cuestión contraria
derecho y la cámara con una apelación
del fiscal termina diciendo no no esa
causa que fue a Santa Cruz tiene que
volver a la justicia Federal de la
ciudad de Buenos Aires Obviamente que
eso y esto también este Santiago creo
que y volviendo a la liga lo que vos
decías creo que también es un punto que
como al proceso penal del juez
independiente estas son cuestiones
también que tienen que ponerse en la
mesa Al momento de discutir una reforma
judicial para los argentinos